- I wanted to find out who I am.
- I wanted to know
what makes me, me.
(inspirational piano music)
- And that's why I
used InThoseGenes
to get my pie chart,
to find out exactly who I am.
- The most surprising
result is that I'm 23%
dumb ass who stands immediately
when the plane lands,
knowing damn well I
ain't going no where.
- I'm 1/3 people
pleaser, 1/3 loud
mouth breather,
and 1/3 a** eater.
Honestly, I thought that
percentage would be much higher
because I love
chewing on that booty.
- I am so excited
to find out that I
am 52% woman who
loudly and confidently
pronounces the L in salmon.
What can I say?
I walk the walk and
I talk the talk.
Why would the L even be there?
- I used to wonder why my
wife and girlfriend hated me.
Now I know it's because
I'm 98% not shit,
ain't never been shit,
and will never be shit.
The other 2%?
Man of God.
- When I found
myself in the trunk
of Diane Keaton's car on
Christmas Eve, high as a kite,
that bitch get turnt,
she stabbed three people.
My results? Oh yeah.
This says I'm 117%
person who has
a short attention span due to
the consumption of hard drugs.
(gasps) Oh, my god.
That's a chart.
- I'm 50% person who
says ax instead of ask.
Must be my Black
part, I'm biracial.
And I'm 50% racist,
which is why I made
that joke about Black people.
Must be my white half.
Can I call the cops on
these results (chuckles)?
I'm only joking, partially.
- Walk, calm, lip balm.
- I'm eating some butt tonight.
- I feel a breeze,
is that a ghost?
- [Narrator] And for
an additional $9.99,
you can trace your
actual genealogy
and find out where
you came from.
- This is a little heavy.
(chains rattling)
Are you for real?
Why do Black folks do this?
(chains rattling)
Who did this?
- [Narrator] InThoseGenes
takes the mystery
out of what makes us this way,
by using our unique
DNA fingerprints
to answer the age-old question,
who am I, who are
you, who are we?
(chains rattling)
(overlapping angry chatter)
- Do you guys have a--
- Wait why does she have a whip?
- Oh it's because I'm biracial.
This is highly problematic but
contextually, very accurate.
(overlapping chatter)
- [Narrator] InThoseGenes,
in no way affiliated
with R&B artist Ginuwine.